Miami Florida a city where happy hour is
a lifestyle colorful over-the-top
bananas on the Caribbean climate and
white sandy beaches have made this city
a playground for the super-rich people
on the outside who will see Miami think
of it's very superficial which it is to
a large degree but Miami is a magnet to
for migrants from Latin America making
this city a multicultural metropolis
licencia de lo Cubano de Lexy Leo padam
okay Miami stop pintado pour pour in the
last 40 years or so it's probably
changed more than any city in the United
States three colorful locals are taking
you on an exclusive tour of their city
opening doors that are there if only you
know where to find them
Cinco mommy
less a ludus Familia Regla Kumbha yo soy
cantante soy parte de la pequeña a la
estoy % ando la baie de ciudad de miami
reg'lar is one of a hundred and forty
thousand Cubans who call Miami home
Miami City second the soon Adela Rowena
hey over the Cuban community makes up a
third of Miami's entire population
Miami is assumed well camera video so
tombe yo Tina tanto para ofrecer pero la
pequeña vana tena koe mo sa pequeno
Corazon de la vie Fidel Castro's ascent
to power in Cuba in 1959 sparked several
waves of mass migration to Miami ha
for reg'lar it's the simple things in
Little Havana that visitors should
experience la gente que viene la pequeña
wanna tiene que tomar el café de la
forma que los vamos la pequeña Vasi ha y
las otras magic et de porque si you know
P de un cafe uno tiene de compartir con
las personas que lo rodea end aha table
let o Havana
desist autumnal Park overlooked by many
visitors to the city right lab rings o
her friends here for the authentic Cuban
Miami experience
solamente una vez la i sin sia de los
quano del ik silly es la comunicación
con lo Cubano de Cuba cuando who gamos
de me no no solve Adamo's de toda la
Penna problema being privy to
conversations of these tables is the
best way to immerse yourself in Little
Havana
I feel that everybody likes the Domino
Park because I get to see the ancestry
when we arrived here in 1961 it was
nothing
we have people from almost every country
in Latin America fortunately we can
become part of the multi pocket for many
Miami really has become the city of
opportunity and those that make it here
are well known to flash their cash
proportionally residents in Miami and
West Palm Beach buy more luxury cars
than anyone else in America
I live the glamorous life haha I like to
think I do
people on the outside who see Miami as a
tourist think of it it's very
superficial which it is to a large
degree but beneath the surface been
refined good people Elaine Lancaster is
a Miami bon viveur socialites
philanthropist and celebrated drag queen
Elaine Lancaster is indicative of Miami
she's colorful
over-the-top we don't know if she's real
or not but we do know one thing she's a
lot of fun she's also an art aficionado
and her number one hangout is the
colorful streets of Miami's
up-and-coming art districts of Winwood
what I have friends who come in from out
of town they always want to see art
because Miami has become synonymous with
the art world this area used to be just
a bunch of pretty much abandoned
warehouses
when the art scene emerged this Linwood
area people came in and started taking
these these spaces in the turret number
two art galleries and when Wood has his
amazing endless blocks and blocks and
blocks of walls that have been taken
over by artists from all over the world
art changes it can stay for a year or
two and then they paint over it another
artist takes over and paints it Wynwood
is home to more than 100 galleries but
Elaine has her personal favorite which
is owned by her great friend javi whose
promised to unveil his latest
masterpiece hi darling Hey
how are you how are you oh yes hey baby
yeah here I'm gonna show you something
oh my goodness she is gorgeous
when you think beautiful I love the
purples
not too many years ago you know this
area Winwood was you did not want to be
here at night sometimes not even in the
daytime and it's amazing how just five
years or three years can really
transform an area when you come to mom
you got to go to windward and the
everyone says I've got to go to windward
and see the walls Miami came of age when
Swiss festival Art Basel started an
offshoot in Miami in 2002 it's now one
of the biggest art fairs in the world
cementing the city's reputation as an
international hotbed for art so really
when people think of Miami they usually
think of the beaches oh yeah and sexy
sexy people and there are per capita
that's so sexy boys and girls and
everything in between they called the
billion dollar sandbar for a reason
Miami may have gone through an
astonishing transformation over the last
50 years but there's one man who stood
the test of time I'm Raven and I've been
running this beach for a 41 years eight
miles a day 120 plus thousand miles
never missed a day
Ravens run an eight mile stretch of
South Beach every single day since 1975
yeah
they say I'm a little obsessive yeah
they tell me that I like routine here we
go it's time for roll call if you want
to explore Miami Beach there's no better
guide than this 65 year old he used to
run with Frankie he used to wear
Skechers sketchy but you're coming here
on a shoestring budget you got to run
with me it's not a few things that's
free more than 3,000 people have run
with Raven over the years including
celebrities like Muhammad Ali the Raven
run is gentle enough to give visitors
time to absorb the atmosphere on this
iconic strip of sand
well I really love about Miami Beach's
when I go out my door it's never boring
sometimes it's like a three-ring circus
out here you turn one way you'll see a
guy riding his bike backwards you turned
the other way you might see some girl
getting pulled by two dogs just never
know what you're gonna see Miami Beach
is entirely man-made 120 years ago this
was swampland one of the historical
facts Raven likes to tell his companions
in the 70s it was rundown it was very
poor especially in South Beach and my
thought is when they started filming
Miami Vice in like 84 or 85 that turned
it around where is close to nature and
God as you can be especially when
especially when it's lightning you're
praying real hard not to get struck no
matter what the weather
Raven knows the best spots to enjoy the
Vista southernmost tip of Miami Beach
right there my favorite place is down by
the pier because you see everything from
the skyline downtown Key Biscayne South
the ocean you know East and the whole
beach going north
I think Miami Beach a common complaint
is that it's very transient city so
people are always coming and going and
Raven defied that transients and he's
here every day when you're out here you
remember what the city is really all
about it's this beautiful stretch of
pristine sand the gorgeous water and
then you look at the development that's
going on and you see some of the older
buildings so from the tourist
perspective it's a great way to see the
city it's become a spiritual thing for
me I've seen every single sunset for 41
years
back in Little Havana the sunset is met
with street music
la musica para nosotros los cubanos y
para mi in particular part nevada un
pueblo say identificar con la music if
you want to enjoy a sundown and see
great cuban musicians doing impromptu
performances then bar Cuba Oh Cho in
Little Havana is a local favorite cuando
yokocho musica no n Alamos
no I nada mi cabeza ma ke s o mi venez
la música y piano el bajo la / q co me
hace sentir Libre
Cuba Otto may not compete with the glitz
and glamour of many Miami bars but its
regulars favorite night spot in Little
Havana its festooned in Cuban art and
there's another reason regular brings
visitors here
después de Volare de cantar EDI answer
me trabajo que me encanta de frutos
centaur may aqui y tomar may UN row
porque Cuba Oh Cho es el mejor lugar de
Miami para tomar Mundra the owner
Roberto Ramos claims to have the best
rum collection in the country Roberto
cake indeed a dallona's tienes a can
take elección hora hora memo's la
colección de una a cuatro sienta Sesenta
Seca begin en Tabo de esto treason llama
llama bendables el santa teresa Mar Seco
pero en más para lo que sabe n erin o
para Galan tarde este Centenario LD
cinco a nose
and run that of macho it's my birthday
my psycho mom
after dark Raven likes to meet with
friends near the beach on world-renowned
Ocean Drive yeah that's where the
Scarface boys that was it that was it
right in the back but you don't have to
come here for partying
Raven prefers the people watching with a
takeout from the Crab Shack well I think
people who move here they they're not
like the typical
people you might meet in Ohio or
something people here are a little bit
more colorful a little more wild well I
think the international flavor of our
community of Miami Beach make it really
attractive people they come down here as
kind of a novelty and then they get
stuck here and living here is being
outside and enjoying yourself it's
become a party city
and nothing says party city like Elaine
Lancaster this is where the party is fun
tonight she's taking us to her favorite
night spot the Ford restaurant is a
mainstay in Miami Beach it's been around
for years everybody goes to the forge I
mean there's every celebrity you can
think of Friday night is my favorite
time of the week because they have Luke
liquor champagne at a reasonable price
and all the pretty people go and hang
the forge is reflective of Miami because
it's so over-the-top the forge has been
an iconic pillar of Miami nightlife for
50 years if you like better way I love
those so where I wait burgundy so you go
both ways I go crazy if you're lucky
enough to bump into the owner Sharif
Malnik you can always black yourself a
tour of the super exclusive vault
welcome to the gorges myself so nice to
be back right now Michael Jackson used
to come here and we did Whitney Houston
come here yes erna Bobby Brown we're
here they came in one night and they
sang a duet to each other across from
the bar house we had a net at dinner
right here and they and Michael Jackson
had his birthday party here and we had
some really nice times with him we take
pride in our wine this is an 18 22
Chateau lafite-rothschild there's only
two left in the world
this was bottled a year after the
passing of
my goodness okay and there it is there
it is
tell me about this what happens with the
if the court cuts back in 1988 the
master corkers from Lafitte from the
Chateau came here to record the bottle
so they take a little bit out of the
dropper and it is still good they'll
record the bottle and give it another 35
years Miami is not a city you'd expect
to uncover historic artifacts but then
again this city is full of surprises if
only you know where to look